بطل اللحظات الحرجه حارس عرين الارجنتين
الرجل الذي يحب ميسي ومستعد للموت من اجله
ليس بالقول فقط بل بالفعل ايضا كيف لا وهو
الذي انقذ مرمى منتخب التانجو من عده كره
خطيره خلال بطوله كاس العالم وقادهم بتصدي
لركله ترجيحيه الى التتويج باللقب
بالاغلاق
ايميليان ومارتيلز كما يراقبه عشاق
الارجنتين كان احد ابطال المنتخب
الارجنتيني في السنوات الاخيره ساهم بعده
القاب بدايه من كوبا امريكا
بكل الجهود التي حققها في بطوله كاس
العالم الاخيره شخصيته مليان والجريئه
والمتحفز جعلته محطه انظار العالم لكن بعد
تصرفاته الطائشه خصوصا في تتويج الارجنتين
الاخير جاء على منه حديث الصحف
والانتقادات حول شخصيته المستفز
من دموع الفقر الى دموع الفرح لحظات وانت
تلخص مسيرتها كفاحا طويله لحارس منتخب
الارجنتين المتوج بكاس العالم مليان
ومارتينيز الذي عاش صبرا مرا لاكثر من عشر
سنوات قبل ان يفتح القدر له ابواب المسجد
الواسعه من مارديل ثلاثه احد مدن العاصمه
الكبيره وخوفه الطبيعي تاركا عائلته
الفقيره لبكاء الفراق وقاطعا المحيط
الاطلسي ليصل الى انجلترا ويوقع عقده هناك
مع فريق ارسنال عام 2010 حيث كانت المهمه
الصعبه في اثبات ذات بعمر صغير لم يتجاوز
حينها العشرين في بريطانيا كانت المهمه
صعبه منافسه شرسه مع كبار حراس الفريق
الاندري منعت الحارس الارجنتيني الصغير من
صنع اسم له ليكون خيار اعارته بالنسبه
لاداره النادي هو الابرز ولينتقل خلال
ثمان سنوات بين عده انديه مغموره كان
افضلها دون ان يضمن مكانا في التشكيل
الاساسي لاي منها العمر يمضي والاحلام
تتبخر لكن لحظه هناك فرصه تلوح بوفقه حياه
مارتيناز الارسنال يفقد حريسه لينو
للاصابه وليس هناك مفر من مشاركه
ايميليانو الذي كان على قدر المهمه
واستطاع حمايه عرين ارسنال ليس ذلك فحسب
بلدهم للتتويج بكاس الاتحاد الانجليزي عام
الامر الذي لم يتحقق اذا ما بقي على مقاعد
البدلاء يختار الانتقال الى الصلب الى
الحارس الاساسي للفريق الجديد الامر الذي
حمله الى حراسه مرمى الارجنتين والاساسيه
بالارجنتين كانت لحظات الفرح الحقيقيه
ثلاث بطولات في اقل من عامين بدايه من كاس
كوبا امريكا ومن بعدها بطوله فينال سيما
ثم كاس العالم اللقب الاغريق مسيره جعلت
من امليانه بطلا حقيقيا في بلاده
وبطوله شعبها الكثير من الانتقادات في
الايام الاخيره بسبب سوء سلوكه بدايه من
الاشاره التي فعلها اثناء التتويج
الارجنتين بكاس العالم ومن بعدها رفعه
لدنيا تشبه في مسيره المنتخب في الارجنتين
يكون الاكثر اثاره الجدل بين اعضاء
التانجو
ينضم لنا في الفيديو الصحفي الرياضي احمد
ابو الشايب احمد يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا
في صباح العربيه صباح الخير عليكم
افضل حارس مرمى في مونديال قطر 2020 كيف
يمكن
يعني اول شيء يعني من النادر جدا ان ينشهر
لاعب بيكون في حراسه المرمى دائما احنا من
ملاحظه اللاعبين بالشهروا بالهجوم بتجديد
الاهداف لكن انه لاعب حارس
ويحضر بكل هذه الشهره للامانه هذه كانت
يعني نقطه الفارقه في حياه مارتنز ايه
الحركه اللي عملها في اخر المباراه حركه
كانت غير لائقه خصوصا انه كاس العالم يعني
ليس كبطوله عاديه دائما همم المتخصصين في
الرياضه او المتابعين الرياضه
لكن كاس العالم يعني انت تعلم كل الكل
يشاهد كاس العالم الكبير الصغير
المثقطع غير المثقف يعني هي بطوله الكل
فانت في هذا الموقف يجب ان توصل رساله
اخلاقيه رساله همم انسانيا رساله اي رساله
تكون ايجابيه للعالم وليس توصل الرساله
يعني مثل هذا الرساله التي وصلتها للناس
هذا يعني هذا الماخذ الذي اخذ على هذا
الحارس الت احمد كيف كمان بدنا نفهم
اخلاقيات لاعبي كره القدم يعني كمان
تصرفات مبابي مع رئيس مكروه اثارت غضبه
السياق كثيرين وليس بالضروره ان يكونوا
فانز ولا مؤيدين للرئيس مكرون لكن يعني
اعتبره انه ما تصرف به البطيخ كان غير
حضاره
حزن بعد خساره لقب بهذا الحجم يعني فرنسا
كانت كل يعني كل مرشح في فرنسا انها تحصل
على لقب كان الصدمه بالنسبه لهم يعني كان
يعني لا يوجد يعني همم دخل المنتخب
الفرنسي المباراه وهو على ثقه كامل لان
البطوله سوف تكون من نصيبه بخصوص انه
الفريق الفرنسي يعني
ابيض طبعا هذا الحزن اعتقد يعني لم يسيطر
على نفسه همم
وظهر بهذه الصوره وكان الرئيس يعني يتكلم
معه بطريقه
يعني كان موقف يعني مثير
خصوصا من مارتيناز من ح ولا دميه عليها
صوره مبابي بشكل الرضيع الى دقيقه الصمت
استهزاء بن بابي هذه التصرفات في ايطار
توضع ضمن عقوبات الفيفا اخلاق رياضيين
واداب الرياضيه في مساله مهمه باللاعبين
الارجنتينيين تحديدا يعني هناك دائما لاعب
الارجنتيني مختلف عن اللاعب الاوروبي
اللاعبين الارجنتينيين في دائما هناك في
بينهم وبين البرازيليين اذا بتلاحظوا يعني
بعد كل لقب او بعد كل فوز او بعد كل خساره
هناك هتافات ضد البرازيليين
يعني عندهم هذه موجوده لهذا الشهر كتصرف
يعني اخلاقي
الفيفا ليس في في قوانين الفيفا ما يعني
عقوبات بهذا الجانب خصوصا ان هذا يعني
المباراه لو داخل المباراه في العقوبه لكن
خارج المباراه
الانجليزي الذي يلعب له همم ماركينيز او
ممكن من المنتخب الارجنتيني يعني ممكن
يتاخذ في عقوبه اخلاقي واعتقد انه يعني
كونا تاتي ضمن التتويج فانا انا لا اتوقع
تكون في عقوبه هناك وفي لا يعاقب عليها
هذه لانا خارجي طيب احمد يعني هل نحن
نحمل اللاعبين مسؤوليه اكبر منهم يعني
كثير منهم من المنتخبات في بلدان غربيه
يعني تربوا في الشارع فنحن يعني نعاملهم
وكانهم نريد ان يكونوا السفراء بلدانها
بالمعنى الوظيفه ان يتزنوا ان يتمثل
بالاتزان والرقي يعني لا سفراء لكره القدم
فقط
همم للنجوميه في العالم حاليا
ليس قديما قديما يعني كان النجم مختلف عن
النجم حاليا الان النجوميه عباره عن
احتراف ومال فقط في السابق كانت النجوم هي
عباره عن رساله يعني انا كل نجم ان كان
كره قدم وكان في اي مكان يجب ان يحمي
الرساله يجب اذا ما حمل رساله هو يعتبر
انسان مشهور فقط اما الانسان لازم اذا كان
هذا اللاعب يجب انه هذا اللاعب اذا كان
خرج الى الاضواء ووصل الى هذا المستوى من
الشهره هو لاعب بكاس العالم واصبح لاعب
يعني كل العالم همم يشير له بالبنان يعني
حارس مثل هذا الحارس همم كان يعني اللي هو
العامل الاساسي لفوز الارجنتين في كاس
العالم يعني ميسي هو النجم الاول لكن هذا
الحارس
الاساسي انت الان يجب ان توصل الرساله
رساله انسانيه رساله حضاريه رساله اخلاقيه
غير رساله المهم ان تكون على ايجابيه فانت
يجب ان كنجم لا تاخذ النجوميه كما انك انت
تخرج على التلفزيون او انك انا تشاهد او
الناس تعرفك لا فقط لا يجب انك تكون انت
تكون كل مكان حتى انا على هذه الرساله لكل
انسان مشهور انه يوجه رساله يجب ان يحمل
رساله يوجهها للناس ويكون قدوه للاجيال
قدوه للناس اللي هي اللي بتشاهده
للاسف شكرا جزيلا صح في الرياضيات